[Music]
hi mystery recapped here today i am
going to explain a chinese film called
the shy guy
spoilers ahead watch out and take care
[Music]
a fictional country named the daughter's
kingdom is ruled by women men are given
no rights no respect and are expected to
be quiet and submissive in daughter's
kingdom the gender roles are changed so
much so that men are catcalled and
harassed in the streets the ones who
retaliate against the absolute law are
sent to a rehabilitation center and
taught how to respect women in such a
world a couple gives birth to their son
named ming his mother is disappointed to
have birthed someone who won't be of any
use to the family throughout his life
ming is compared to his non-existent
sister he is denied good education and
health facilities because his mother
wishes to save money if she ever gets
pregnant with a daughter as time passes
mingro's resentful of the entire female
gender and starts a rebellious
organization of his own he and his
friends chan and zhang conspire every
day to end the rule of women but all
they can do is talk since anyone who
acts on such urges is punished one
afternoon they are with a new addition
to the group discussing their role in
the world as men as always ming speaks
against the matriarchal society suddenly
the guys noticed that the new man smells
of flowers if a guy puts effort to look
presentable it means he is doing so to
please a woman ming suspects the new man
is a spy and his assumption turns out to
be true suddenly their hideout is raided
and the police arrest them ming's mother
arrives at the scene and reveals that
she was the one who reported him having
found out about the organization
following that the guys are taken to the
highly secured rehabilitation center it
has more than a hundred women guards who
keep an eye on the men at all times the
place is surrounded by high walls barbed
wire and an automatic main entrance any
man who tries to escape will have their
manhood taken away that's a fancy way of
saying they'll have their dicks blown
off the leader of the place is the
ruthless grand instructor in a monthly
meeting she introduces a rookie teacher
named mina the staff of the
rehabilitation center is divided into
two groups working under the grand
instructor first are the guards who are
responsible to punish and discipline men
second are the teachers who are
partnered with an individual man and
tasked to teach them how to please a
woman the new batch of men is brought to
a room to take their clothes off mang
and his friends get ready to run away
but another man does it before them
after seeing him get tased to the ground
they simply step back then they are
forcefully made to take a shower and
wear clothes to look more presentable to
women the grand instructor tells them
about the curriculum they will have to
learn in the next month if they are
unable to pass the final test or try to
create trouble they will be given a
special serum called the cancer liquid
it forcefully turns men submissive and
makes them act womanly if given a larger
dose it completely transforms a man into
a woman by today's standards this script
is problematic before the classes start
the men are paired with their respective
teachers ming is partnered with the new
girl mina he refuses to respect her but
since mina is a rookie she lets it slide
when no one is looking she shows him the
picture of her brother inquiring if he
has seen him around ming doesn't know
the guy but says that he doesn't tell on
his own people the lessons finally begin
starting the next day the first lesson
teaches the men how to take a perfect
picture of their partner for the second
one they are taught how to find out what
their girl wants without her saying it
the third lesson is about how to notice
the small changes the girls make in
their appearance with the three holy
grails of pleasing a woman they will be
considered a useful man during practice
mina again asks ming about her brother a
flashback shows us that he was treated
like trash by his mother he was
frequently insulted and belittled
because of this he hated every woman
except his sister one day he saved her
from the bullies in the street by
pushing them away when his mother found
out he had attacked a woman she called
the police and got him arrested he was
sent to the rehabilitation center hence
mina is in here to look for her brother
when it gets dark everyone is sent to
their respective rooms ming and his
group are devising a plan to escape when
they notice an opening to a tunnel under
the table in their room however they are
joined by a snitch named jison so they
decide to explore the tunnel when he is
asleep somewhere else mina asks her
roommate teite about the guys who were
denied rehabilitation because they were
too disobedient she finds out that all
of such men have been given the cancer
serum that turns them womanlike in
nature they are kept in the basement
prison and will be there for the rest of
their lives when everyone is asleep mina
goes to the basement and sees several
men inside the cells however her brother
is missing suddenly a loud noise is
heard and ming comes out of a hole in
the wall he spreads his arms thinking
that he has escaped only to find out he
is inside a cell mina sees him but she
doesn't report the act to the grand
instructor she then goes to the filing
room and finds out that her brother
escaped from the prison a while ago she
also gets her hands on a poem he wrote
about men's suffering what mina doesn't
realize is that taete is spying on her
the following morning mina tells ming
that she is leaving her job now that she
knows her brother is not here ming is
surprised to see a woman being so
compassionate suddenly teite comes in
with the grand instructor and finds the
poem on mina she is about to be punished
when ming claims that he wrote the poem
and she just confiscated it as a result
he is tased but he bears the pain for
her later that day mina comes to meet
and thanks him for what he did ming
hands her the poem that he had hidden in
his pockets at midnight ming picks the
lock of his cell and comes outside with
his friends they go to the main gate and
are seconds away from escaping when the
women block their way it turns out that
their roommate told the grand instructor
about their absence taytay suggests they
use the cancer serum on the guys but
mina suggests a better option if they
use force to discipline the guys people
will question their rehabilitation
program hence she asks for one last
chance to try to change ming if she
doesn't succeed she promises to stay as
the rehabilitation guard for her entire
life the following day meena hands the
rule book to ming and asks him to
memorize everything when he still
refuses she slaps him across his face
she is scared for him because his
failure will turn him into a woman and
imprison him for life on finding out
that mina cares about him he agrees to
make an effort to pass in the following
montage we see mina teaching him how to
take good pictures one evening she
invites him to eat with her taytay sees
this and is outraged by a man getting
the same level of respect as a woman she
takes a picture of them and shows it to
the grand instructor mina is called into
her office and asked to explain herself
she lies and claims that she is trying
to make ming fall in love with her so
she can mend him easily the grand
instructor buys her words but not taete
she records the conversation and gives
the tape to ming later after listening
to it he believes that mina is only
using him to make him submissive he
refuses to talk to her and goes back to
being a rebel he dresses as he wants to
and makes his friends do the same as a
result all three of them are signed up
for the cancer serum program and mina is
punished her failure means she will have
to stay as a guard her entire life she
is also made to take a liquid called the
iron blood that does strange things to
her body following the cancer serum
treatment the guys lose their minds
fortunately for ming the side effects
did not affect him as they do to his
friends mina comes to him and reveals
that she is in love with him she also
explains that there is a serum called
iron blood that makes women more
powerful it is an antidote for the
cancer serum and if given to his friends
they will return to normal having said
that mina lies that the instructor has
kicked her out the two share a tearful
goodbye and promise to meet each other
outside one day when she is no longer in
his view mina falls to the ground in
pain her body starts changing because of
the medication she was given as
punishment for the next few days ming
studies hard so he can excel on the
final test that way he can get to the
grand instructor's room and find the
antidote to save his friends meanwhile
his friends hit on him has the effect of
the treatment then the day of the test
finally comes for the first round the
guys are let into a room with different
items they have to choose one of the
items which they think women will like
the most ming's friend picks up a
diamond ring and hands it to him when
evaluation starts the ring gets ming
through the first round similarly the
guy with perfume and a dress also passes
the first in class is jison who picked a
set of earrings for the second round
they are given a scenario of a couple
spending the day together they have to
tell how many times the girlfriend was
mad at the boyfriend in the scenario
ming writes four but the guard nearby
gestures that zero is the right answer
ming trusts her and passes this round as
well for the third and final round only
he and g son are left they have to
inspect taytay closely for 10 seconds
after that she goes to the back of a
room and returns with very minimal
changes in her appearance the guys have
to tell what is different jison goes
first and takes a close look at her face
he confidently claims that she added a
bit of foundation and blush to her face
then it is ming's turn but he sees no
difference at all he looks at the guard
who helped him earlier hoping to get a
hint she simply shows him the poem that
he had given to meena long ago suddenly
ming comes to a realization the manly
guard is none other than mina who was
given the iron blood it is a type of
medicine that turns women manly in
contrast to what the cancer serum does
looking at taytay he confidently claims
that she is not tate at all the grand
instructor takes her wig off and reveals
the answer is correct ming finally gets
first place defeating jisan to receive
his present he is invited to the grand
instructor's room at night she
seductively asks him to pour them a
drink ming takes this chance to slip a
pill into her glass this script
continues to be problematic a while
later she falls unconscious and ming
excitedly opens the safe however the
serums are nowhere to be found the
instructor wakes up revealing that she
knew about his plan he is about to be
arrested when mina makes him run outside
a fight ensues between mina and the
guards amidst it the instructor is hit
by an iron blood syringe that will turn
her manly before she can take the
antidote ming stops her it is then
revealed that the instructor also used
to be a man he was like ming and wanted
to introduce men's rights to the world
however he was locked and beaten which
caused him to change into a woman using
several doses of the iron blood serum
the instructor finally sees herself in
ming and allows him to escape in the
last scene she drops him his friends and
mina outside the facility the movie ends
as she watches them walk away
subscribe for more videos like this turn
on notifications and leave a like to
help the channel out thank you for
watching